talk about  the title trap art because i feel like  you're like you said you're like an  artist artist you could really do  anything and and i feel like that's kind  of a dope  title for if you were to just kind of  box in  your genres give it a name yeah  but trap in my generation is  always thought when you think of trap  you think of like down south traffic of  course you think of like  g-z-z-t exactly my version of trap  is like the west coast trap the  sugar-free the two shirts of the world  and you know what i'm saying stuff like  that and artistic side it's just  me being me that's where you get just me  being me i might  one track i may do something you know  i'm saying or go or stay standard you  never know what you go get with me